en este vídeo vamos a presentar la idea
de la espectroscopia de foto emisión es
una forma de analizar la configuración
electrónica de una muestra de cierto
tipo de átomo puede que veas algo como
esto en un examen es un espectro de foto
emisión que se ve así y la primera
pregunta es bueno qué está pasando
cómo se genera esto no voy a entrar en
detalles pero el panorama general es que
el análisis se realizará tomando una
corriente de un átomo hay una corriente
atómica yendo en una dirección déjenme
etiquetar esto de modo que estos son los
átomos que estamos tratando de analizar
y luego en la otra dirección se envían
fotones de alta energía que van a
bombardear esos átomos fotones ahora
estos fotones tienen suficiente energía
de hecho típicamente son fotones de
rayos x para que cuando choquen la
energía de los fotones sea suficiente
para superar la energía de enlace
incluso de los electrones centrales y
esos electrones sean eliminados y se
alejen y entren en un campo magnético
que los en ciará y hará que golpeen
puedes imaginar que los electrones que
están más cerca del núcleo son los que
tienen la energía de enlace más alta por
lo que se va a usar más energía del
fotón para superarla y le quedará menos
para la energía cinética esos electrones
más cercanos no llegarán tan lejos los
electrones externos tienen la energía de
enlace más baja y por lo tanto es más
fácil de eliminar entonces más energía
del fotón se transferirá a la energía
cinética y van a llegar más lejos van a
golpear el detector en un punto más
lejano una forma de ver el espectro de
foto emisión es que te da una idea de
aproximadamente cuántos electrones
tienen varias energías de enlace y vemos
que la energía de enlace aumenta a
medida que avanzamos hacia la izquierda
ahora esto tiene sentido porque la
energía de enlace es inversamente
proporcional a la cantidad de energía
cinética que tienen estos electrones ya
que en realidad son eliminados este pico
es nuestro espectro en el extremo
izquierdo corresponde a los electrones
más internos y éstos serán electrones
más lejanos
la siguiente cantidad inferior de
energía de enlace y después de eso baja
la energía de enlace de modo que podemos
analizar esto para llegar a la
configuración electrónica de este
elemento misterioso que tenemos aquí
cuál crees que sería pausa este vídeo y
trata de pensar en esto bueno como
mencioné este pico que tenemos aquí se
usa para detectar los electrones más
internos que son los electrones de 1s y
sabemos que esos no son los únicos
electrones porque hay electrones que
tienen energías de enlace más bajas y
que habrían llenado esta capa más
interna también sabemos que tienen dos
electrones 1s y luego podemos pensar que
en este próximo pico están los dos
electrones de la sub capa 2s
y tenemos más electrones de modo que
debemos haber llenado la sub capa 2s y
luego este siguiente pico se parece a
dos p y la razón por la que esto
realmente tiene mucho sentido es que
podemos observar que el detector
registra más electrones aquí y también
tenemos más electrones
por lo que este debe haberse llenado en
realidad no siempre va a ser tan
perfecto como esto fue construido pero
puedes ver que tienes aproximadamente
tres veces más electrones 2p que
electrones 2s lo que tiene sentido las
dos sub capas pueden tener seis
electrones las dos sub capas s tienen
dos este próximo pico va a ser la
siguiente capa más alta de energía que
tendrá una energía de enlace más baja es
más fácil eliminar esos electrones así
que parece que este es 3s 2 y luego este
siguiente pico parece que es 3 p 6 y ese
se llena por completo y tenemos un pico
más después de eso y ese pico parece
tener aproximadamente el mismo número de
electrones que todas las otras sub capas
s sabemos por el principio de aub av que
en seguida llenamos 4s y parece que hay
dos electrones allí porque este pico es
como las otras sub capas ese y es así
como podemos usar un espectro de foto de
misión para llegar a la configuración
electrónica
elemento misterioso su configuración
electrónica es 1 s 2 2 s 22 p 6 3 s 23 p
64 s 2 y que el elemento tiene esta
configuración electrónica bueno lo hemos
trabajado en otros vídeos pero puedo
sacar mi tabla periódica de elementos
veamos
1 s 2 nos lleva al helio 2s 22 p 6 nos
llevan león 3 s 2 3 p 6 nos lleva al
argón y luego 4 s 2 nos lleva al calcio
así que nuestro elemento misterioso es
calcio y si alguien preguntara sobre
electrones de valencia sería el pico más
externo que tenemos aquí el pico de
electrones con la energía de enlace más
baja tienen la energía de enlace más
baja porque son los más alejados son los
más fáciles de eliminar y debido a eso
la mayor parte de esa energía fotónica
que sobra después de superar la energía
de enlace se convierte en energía
cinética entonces esos electrones se
desvían aún
y la base de lo que vemos aquí es el
espectro de foto electrones de calcio
como esperaríamos que fuera el espectro
de foto emisión de potasio y sólo como
recordatorio el potasio tiene un número
atómico de 19 de modo que tiene 19
protones en el núcleo mientras que el
calcio tiene 20 protones en el núcleo y
vamos a suponer que estamos hablando de
un átomo de potasio neutro entonces
también tendrá 19 electrones pausa este
vídeo y piensa en cuál sería la
diferencia cuando pensamos en el potasio
va a tener un espectro de foto emisión
muy similar al del calcio pero como sólo
tiene 19 versus 20 protones tiene menos
carga positiva en el núcleo así que tira
un poco menos fuerte en nuestras sub
capas así que el potasio va a tener 1s 2
pero va a tener una energía de enlace
ligeramente más baja porque no está
atraído tanto hacia el núcleo y no lo
estoy dibujando perfectamente puede que
no sea tanto en realidad probablemente
sea algo como esto pero va a estar un
poco a la derecha
del mismo modo 2 s 2 va a estar un poco
a la derecha y luego 2 p 6 va a estar un
poco a la derecha y una vez más no lo
estoy dibujando completamente a la
perfección porque no tengo los datos
exactos aquí 3 s 2 va a estar un poco a
la derecha una vez más sólo 19 protones
versus 20 para calcio así que tiramos un
poco menos hacia adentro entonces
tenemos una energía de enlace más baja
para cualquier capa o sub capa dada 3 p
6 va a estar un poco a la derecha algo
así de modo que como se verá la sub capa
4 s bueno no tiene dos electrones en la
sub capa 4 s sólo tiene uno porque sólo
tiene 19 electrones y no 20 y entonces
va a estar un poco a la derecha tiene
una energía de enlace más baja y sólo va
a ser la mitad de alto porque sólo
tienes un electrón nodos se vería algo
así así sería el espectro de foto
emisión de potasio aproximadamente ya
hemos hablado de que su capa más externa
muestra dónde están los l
de valencia así que si estamos pensando
en el potasio estaría justo aquí ahora
eso también nos dice que cuando estamos
pensando en la energía de enlace por
aquí
esta es la energía de enlace nos dice
cuánta energía necesitamos para quitar
un electrón cuando estás eliminando ese
primer electrón esta es tu primera
energía de ionización una vez que
elimines es el primer electrón debido a
todas las interacciones entre los
electrones su espectro de futura emisión
cambiaría de modo que no puedes pensar
en una segunda o tercera energía de
ionización pero tu primera energía de
ionización es la energía de enlace de
sus electrones más externos